[Applause]
once again people took the streets of
sudan
thousands rallied in cartoon
it's divine city om durman
and across the nile river in hartung
north
despite security forces closing bridges
and main roads and shutting down the
internet for nearly three weeks they are
demanding a return to the transition
process and a civilian-led government
the military takeover two weeks ago
dissolved the transitional government
and arrested senior governments
officials and political figures from the
forces of freedom and change coalition
we the sudanese people will not accept a
military rule we don't want any
negotiations or compromise we want
civilians only to rule our country
the civilian groups including the forces
of freedom and change have called on
people to attend the mass protests on
saturday and people have responded they
are demanding an immediate restoration
of the civilian government the release
of the political prisoners and for the
army to commit to the constitutional
declaration it's signed with civilian
leaders in 2019
unarmed protesters were met with tear
gas
and live ammunition
people have been killed people have been
imprisoned and tortured there's nothing
worse than death and we have seen our
brothers being killed in front of us so
we are not going back the head of the
army has to be held accountable
the political crisis deepened when the
head of the army general abdulfatal
burhan formed a new ruling sovereign
council on thursday
the 14-member council includes army
leaders and civilians from across sudan
but not from the forces of freedom and
change we can see that in the
appointments that have been made in the
sovereign council and several of the
civilian members who do not represent
not just the ffc that the sort of um
political party model but any of their
revolutionary bodies so no one from
youth groups no one from anybody who
took part in in the
revolution to unseat bashir so what
we're seeing is very much a continuation
of the old bashir regime and it's meant
to be representative it's meant to be
you know you're meant to have someone
from the north from the center and
someone from the east was yet to be um
announced but no one feels that this
body actually represents uh the people
of sudan and so there's a lot of anger
today about just to what extent the
military is and entrenching its rule at
the moment mediation enforced by the
united nations as well as several other
countries have failed to end sudan's
crisis
protesters say they will continue to
voice the rejection of the army they
have called for similar protests in the
coming days saying they will only stop
when civilians are in charge of the
government
resulter al-jazeera khartoum